and you started talking about uh dave
romohart so who is this person
that was so
you've spoken very highly of him yeah
can you tell me about him his ideas his
mind who he was as a human being as a
scientist
so dave came from a little tiny town in
western south dakota
and
his
mother was the librarian and his father
was the editor of the newspaper
um
and uh i know one of his brothers pretty
well um
they grew up
there were four brothers
and
they grew up
together
and their father encouraged them to
compete with each other a lot
they competed in sports and they
competed in mind games you know um
i don't know things like sudoku and
chess and various things like that
and uh
dave um
was
a standout undergraduate he went
as at a younger age than most people do
to college
at the university of south dakota and
majored in mathematics and i don't know
how he got interested in
psychology but he applied to the
mathematical psychology program at
stanford and was accepted as a phd
student
to study mathematical psychology at
stanford so mathematical psychology
uh is the
use of mathematics to model
mental processes right so something that
i think these days might be called
cognitive modeling that whole space yeah
it's mathematical in the sense that
you say
if
this is true and that is true then i can
derive that this should follow okay and
so you say these are my stipulations
about the fundamental principles and
this is my prediction about behavior and
it's all done with equations it's not
done with the computer simulation
right so the you you solve the equation
and that tells you what the
probability that the subject will be
correct on the seventh trial of the
experiment is or something like that
right so it's a it's a it's a
it's a
use of mathematics to descriptively
characterize uh aspects of of behavior
and uh stanford at that time was the
place where
uh there were several really really
strong mathematical thinkers who were
also connected with three or four others
around the country
who um you know brought a lot of really
exciting ideas onto the table
and it was a very very prestigious part
of the field of psychology at that time
so remember heart comes into this
he was a very strong student within that
program
uh and
uh
he got
this
job at this brand new university in san
diego in 1967
he's one of the first
assistant professors in the department
of psychology uh at ucsd
so
i got there
in 74 seven years later
and
ronald hart at that time
was
still doing mathematical modeling
um
but he had gotten interested in
cognition
he'd gotten interested in
understanding
and you know understanding i think
remains
you know what does it mean to understand
anyway you know
uh it's it's interesting sort of curious
you know like how would we know if we
really understood something but
but he was
interested in building machines that
would you know hear a couple of
sentences and have an insight about what
was going on so for example one of his
favorite things at that time was
um
marky was sitting on the front step when
she heard the familiar jingle
of the good humor man
she remembered her birthday money and
ran into the house
what is maggie doing
why
well
there's a couple of ideas you could have
but
the most natural one is that
the good humor man brings ice cream she
likes ice cream she's
she knows she needs money to buy ice
cream so she's gonna run into the house
and get her money so she can buy herself
an ice cream it's a huge amount of
inference that has to happen to get
those things to link up with each other
and and he was interested in how the
hell that could happen
and he was trying to build um
you know good old-fashioned a.i
style
models of
representation of language and
and content of
you know things like
has money
so like a lot of like formal logic and
like knowledge bases like that kind of
stuff yeah so he was integrating that
with his thinking about cognition yes
the mechanisms cognition
how can they like mechanistically be
applied to build these knowledge like to
actually build something that looks like
a web of knowledge and thereby from from
there emerges something like
understanding whatever the heck that is
yeah he was grappling this was something
that they grappled with at the end of
that book that i was describing
explorations and cognition
but he was realizing that the paradigm
of
good old-fashioned ai wasn't giving him
the answers to these questions yeah
and by the way that's called good
old-fashioned ai now it was called that
well it was it was beginning to be
called that
because it was from the 60s yeah yeah by
by the late 70s it was kind of
old-fashioned and it hadn't really
panned out you know and
people were beginning to recognize that
but
and and remember heart was you know like
yeah it was part of the recognition that
this wasn't all working
anyway so he um
started thinking in terms of
uh
the idea that we needed systems that
allowed us to integrate multiple
simultaneous constraints
in a way that would be mutually
influencing each other
so
um
he wrote a paper that
just
really
first time i read it i said oh well you
know yeah
but is this important but after a while
it just got under my skin
and it was called an interactive model
of reading and in this paper he laid out
the idea that
every aspect
of
our
interpretation of
what what's coming off the page when we
read
at every level of analysis you can think
of
actually depends on all the other levels
of analysis
so
what are the actual
pixels
making up each letter and
what do those pixels signify about which
letters they are and what do those
letters tell us about
what words are there
and one of those words tell us about
what ideas the author is trying to
convey and
so he had this model where
you know we have these
little tiny
uh
elements that represent each of the
pixels of each of the letters and then
other ones that represent the line
segments in them and other ones that
represent the letters and other ones
that represent the words
and
um at that time his idea was there's
this set of experts
there's an expert about how to
construct a line out of pixels and
another expert about how
which sets of lines go together to make
which letters and another one about
which letters go together to make bench
words and another one about what the
meanings of the words are and another
one about
how the meanings fit together and you
know things like that and all these
experts are looking at this data and
they're
they're um
updating
hypotheses at at other levels so the
word expert can tell the letter expert
oh i think there should be a t there
because i think there should be a word
the here and the bottom up sort of
feature to letter expert could say i
think there should be a t there too and
if they agree
then you see a t right and so there's a
top-down bottom-up interactive process
but it's going on at all layers
simultaneously so everything can filter
all the way down from the top as well as
all the way up from the bottom and it's
a completely interactive bi-directional
parallel distributed process that is
somehow because of the abstractions it's
hierarchical so like yeah so there's
different layers of responsibilities
different levels of responsibilities
first of all it's fascinating to think
about it in this kind of mechanistic way
so not thinking purely
from the structure of a neural network
or something like a neural network but
thinking about these little little guys
that work on letters and then the
letters come words and words become
sentences
and uh that's a very interesting
hypothesis that from that
kind of hierarchical structure can
emerge
understanding yeah so but the thing is
though i want to just sort of
relate this to the earlier part of the
conversation
um
when rommel heart was first thinking
about it there were these experts on the
side
one for the features and one for the
letters and one for how the letters make
the words and so on
and and they would each be working sort
of
evaluating various propositions about
you know is this combination of features
here going to be one that looks like the
letter t and so on
and
and what he
realized kind of after reading hinton's
dissertation and
hearing about jim anderson's
linear algebra-based neural network
models that i was telling you about
before was that he could replace those
experts with neuron-like processing
units which just would have their
connection weights that would do this
job
so there so
what ended up happening was that
romohart and i got together and we
created a model called the interactive
activation model of letter perception
which is
takes these
little pixel level uh inputs
constructs
uh
line segment features
letters and words but now we built it
out of a set of neuron like processing
units that are just connected to each
other
with connection weights so the unit for
the word time has a connection to the
unit for the letter t in the first
position and the letter i in the second
position
so on
and
because these connections are
bi-directional
if you have prior knowledge that it
might be the word time that starts to
prime the feature to the letters and the
features and if you don't then it's it
has to start bottom up but the
directionality just depends on where the
information comes in first and it and if
you have context together with features
at the same time they can convergently
result in an emergent perception and
that
um that was the um
the piece of work that we did together
that uh
sort of got us both completely convinced
that you know this neural network way of
thinking was going to be able to
actually address the questions that we
were interested in as cognitive cycle so
the algorithmic side the optimization
side those are all details like when you
first start
the idea that you can get far with this
kind of way of thinking that in itself
is a profound idea
you